that is uh who you think you should be
and not who you actually are just like
play a character of yourself
am i not already doing that like all the
time you're playing a character of a
rock star uh-huh
so i do like to watch slightly
right ring right wing stuff slightly
yeah like jordan peterson and
is he is he would he be considered right
wing yes just because he's got
like a suit on and like he doesn't
believe in transgender people is that it
doesn't believe in him yeah
yeah he doesn't believe him they don't
exist i mean
your dad dressed up like a woman yeah
well not all of them but yeah
three but he's also like hearkening back
to christianity and he's like everyone
should be monogamous and women shouldn't
wear makeup in the office
pre-marital divorce should pre-marital
divorce
before you're married i'm a proponent to
divorce before the marriage
wasn't that putting the cart before the
horse
um no it's this is a different thing
entirely i'm talking about marriage
man you don't like marriage no i mean i
don't like
i don't like women to start with and
then
gay thing is just gay it's gay and
stupid
but uh then maybe you just don't like
people
no i just don't like the the eternal
union of any two people
because it hurts your heart it doesn't
hurt my heart
to except to think that anyone would
i i would hate to meet the person who
could tolerate me forever that would be
like the only thing worse than me would
be someone who was like no this guy's
cool
like forever what if it's just someone
who's like
barely there and they're like you know
say
two words oh i've got a wall flower
they're like hanging off your arm and
they don't really have to do anything
with their life that would be awful
that would be awful i would i wouldn't
have respect for that person i can't
i wouldn't have respect for that as a
person though like i would be i would be
i would be awful to a person who just
should respect you you're great
well but that's not a person who
deserves respect if there's a person who
is like
fawning over me and like is reliant on
me
like that person doesn't deserve respect
because i'm i'm nothing i'm worthless
like it's always like oh i yeah i
wouldn't even be able to choose solid
food if it weren't
you don't think that you're worthy so
you're not going to respect anyone who
likes you
no it's not the people who like me it's
the people who count on me that i don't
have respect for
so you're not gonna like be with anyone
no i'm i'm
gonna rely on you no i'm with people and
like i i provide for people
occasionally but as soon as it seems
like they need me
i'm like you you like had a lapse in
reason
to think that i'm the person who's gonna
help you with whatever you need so
you're never
gonna have someone that's gonna need you
no i hope
i mean i hope for their sake no well
maybe you should turn yourself into
someone that can be relied upon
i've tried i've tried watch i'll do it
right now
you can't do it did i do it yes
oh okay i rely on you to not make this
podcast boring
i don't know that i can help you with
that you're doing it currently this is
fascinating sometimes i like to go
get chicken ramen noodle right
uh-huh and then i get the oriental kind
also
okay and i split the yeah they come in
like tiles i split them in half
tiles and then i put a little bit of the
chicken kind in with a little bit of the
nice oriental kind the pouch the
the spices yeah yeah split it in half
yeah but i like just for continuity to
mix the noodles too i know it's
not and i know it doesn't really matter
but like so i can't rely on you because
you do that
and then i put them in some boiling
water right yeah
and then i've got oriental chicken ramen
wow
that sounds reliable yeah
so i mean i mean it's not really about
marriage uh yeah i was just trying to
show you how boring it could be
oh [ __ ] you just sabotaged my [ __ ]
podcast dude yeah you want some soup
no we're recording a podcast get your
head in the game
okay so here this is my new idea for a
podcast
it's called one word right so this will
be an example of how it sounds like
[ __ ] this episode of one word brought
to you by
audible right [ __ ]
so that was episode two yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
it'll all be things about women yeah
because you hate them
i don't hate them i just like saying
mean things to them that make them cry
why because they're so easy to hurt no
because they're fragile
they're easy they're easy to break i
said and then saying
in another word because they're easy to
break it's not that they're easy to hurt
if they're easy if it was the fact that
they were easy to hurt i wouldn't
break them i want them to be you want to
break them yeah like the difference
i don't want them to suffer i just want
them to no longer
no longer be viable you know as a human
being with my words
you want to destroy them um
yeah i mean that's i don't want to watch
women ride through their birth canals
women who will who will uh want to be
with you
in fact a lot of them because they like
the challenge or whatever
because like women you know some of them
are good at withstanding shitty men
i'm just kidding i don't i don't hate
women at all i i don't
know yeah you don't you hate being in a
relationship with human beings because
no i don't hate yourself no i don't well
i do there are things i hate about it
because i know that i
can't even count on myself so when other
people do
and then i can't i can't hold up what
their expectations were of me
i'm like frustrated because like if i
let me down that's that's standard
that's like par for the course
yeah but like if so if i have to let
someone else down it's like i get
frustrated because i was like i told you
not to
rely on me and you still chose to do it
logical
and like a puzzle and you're like i
don't like you because of this
elaborate series of logic and i don't i
don't
i don't believe you yeah i don't like me
or or them
that you are trying to make it sound
like you don't like people but actually
you like them too much and you get hurt
by them and that's why you have a crusty
exterior
no i do like people i do and like i do
my best to
uh have like uh
moments of like like random acts of
kindness and [ __ ] but like
they have to be small because i know
that i can't even
have random acts of kindness for myself
that require any kind of real
responsibility
because i like i can't wake up on time
for anything yeah
you like what we had like because i just
parked in your
place and now i'm leaving yeah that's
great yeah like i'm happy to be able to
do that and it required nothing for me
really it just required me to not
burn everything within that five yard
radius of my house down well you're good
at that and i think that's true kindness
and we have this
artificial bureaucratic systematic
kindness
that we think is a real thing but it's
more like
uh capitalism and real kindness is like
just talking to people and doing
being there for them and doesn't have to
require a lot yeah for you to give up a
lot
but just have a good heart but i mean
like to you're not a good person just
because you don't do bad things
you're a good person because you opened
up your heart
to me yeah i mean like i think it
probably just boils down to like
examination of yourself like no matter
what you've done
like no matter how bad it's been like
the moment that you start to examine it
and like
actually be analytical with yourself
about it then that means that you're
within reach of redemption which is
really all you need because everybody's
a [ __ ] up yeah yeah well i think jordan
peterson
is not um my favorite
but you know everyone has their
different little things and i don't mean
to criticize your
i don't think that he's my favorite in
the slightest there are some ideas that
he has that are great
i think like his idea about
talking in a kermit the frog voice all
the time does he do kermit the frog
voice
i'm so smart yeah i noticed that he ends
a lot of his more like
on the money points with he just says so
song and then and then moves on but not
not with the beginning of the next
sentence being so
he just says so and that's like the
period in between the paragraphs and
then
moves on to the next part it's it's it
makes sense in his head to
sort of end things with the so
so so
uh but yeah i mean i think that he is a
thinker
and i think that he is right on some
things but i think the foundation of his
ideas that this society is
just has to go back to the past is wrong
and i think we should progress
does he think about it yeah he's like
we gotta all be christians we gotta all
have monogamy it's like [ __ ] this is
ancient
[ __ ] that we found doesn't work yeah
i mean there's all kinds of like things
there's like no matter
what you think of someone there's like
good ideas and bad ideas like
know like hitler like people think they
always think of the same thing
it's like it's [ __ ] up but like if you
really think about it and like really
look at everything he did
he did kill all those jews so that's
pretty good that's a good great idea
six million great ideas the vegetarian
thing not so much
yeah it's not a [ __ ]
but um yeah i mean i think that the
chapo trap house is good i think what
does chavo trap house
it's uh these like internet nerds who
are like
trying to be a nerd about politics and
they're like
uh look at it as a game it's like
material conditions of people let's
improve it by
giving them like what they need instead
of like arguing about cancel culture or
whatever it's like playing civilization
but with
everyone yeah i mean they're really
snarky and they're like
look at this stupid uh operator culture
or whatever and like do you remember
[ __ ] lapses
he did on his podcast he did like uh the
flint
clint he didn't know he did uh the like
race war of the entire globe but like
fantasy football
oh yeah like who would win yeah white
people
middle east second to last i think it
would be white people or people who wish
they were white
well that would be like a whole other
diaspora now it's not just white people
it's like
there's black trump supporters because
it's like an idea that you just have to
be a selfish little [ __ ] and
like kanye is just like trying to be
annoying when he supports him though
right
i feel like he's like african-americans
have been in america too long and some
of them have
gone they're like maybe they do have
some good ideas these americans but then
there's like great revolutionaries like
fred hampton
mm-hmm and others but i mean
good at uh producing great um
revolutionaries because we're too
focused on ourselves and we can't reward
the good parts of others but
i try to i mean i don't know when to
though because i don't know when
they need it because like sometimes
sometimes it's like if somebody is like
way too like yeah that was great it's
like i
i need to have a more measured reward
system in my head of how much i tell
myself that that was great
you know yeah because when you do it
because
when you do something well you tell
yourself like oh i'm amazing
of course the [ __ ] did something well
like i always do things
well and then like you don't like you
just absorb things like that
and then like when you do something
poorly or like
you like freaked out i don't i don't
really freak out that much
anymore i just like i think that i need
to find the right balance between like
accepting that like the negative
feelings that come with doing something
wrong are like an important part of
growing because like that's you're the
body's antibody for like
you won't do that again because you felt
so poorly after you did it yeah
um you remember it yeah but like
i don't know um on the flip side like
when people over compliment you it's
like that's not productive either
you have to have a measured idea of
your abilities yeah
i think i'm single because i have
high expectations of people and i think
that a lot of people
are broken by capitalism this is
you just think about this in your van
yeah
i want one of your fans like i agree
with you completely like i
as far as i'm concerned if you can do it
yourself you should always do it
yourself
if you're able to it's not a society
that you can rely on
yeah they'll [ __ ] you yeah yeah for sure
you gotta do it on your own and i wish i
didn't because now i have to like
and yeah
yeah you gotta take it because that's
what america's
all about they respect that amia
close my door real quick you probably
just kicked the
school is it hooked up to this battery
no i'm charging that battery or i was
trying to
okay
right here
there we go okay so
what do you think about keto goth
ketogoth
i mean uh what do you think about
scrapping
what do you like about it and how do you
think it helps you
in your life it's a way to not have a
boss
which is probably the most important
function for me personally is i can't
have people tell me what to do
why not because as soon as someone tells
me what to do
like even if if someone tells me what to
do and i was already gonna do it i have
to not do it i don't know why i'm like
that but it's just
keep breathing i'm breathing yeah doing
what i told you to do you know [ __ ]
i mean i don't want to but i don't
really have much of a choice right yeah
so you have to do whatever but you can't
fire me from life like if that says
something to do
like you keep being asian ones
you know negative uh reverse psychology
complex
i know it's weird it's a weird one yeah
well maybe uh the nature of power
is um it's the nature of authority that
bothers me is it
arbitrary and this is not a good way
to structure or have a hierarchy is to
have
one person with dubious merit tell
others what to do
yeah any any any mayor any
authority that's just like [ __ ] out
of nowhere is is
is pointless like if you can't examine
it and like if somebody's like this is
what we're gonna do and then if you
approach it and you're like well what if
we analyze it and that doesn't make any
sense
we're still going to do it because i'm
the authority figure then like
i've lost respect for them yeah and it's
not an efficient way to organize a
society because
if we all have brains and we can like go
out into the world like
and figure out what's right and what's
the best thing to do
then we should do that instead of just
sacrificing our brains and having one
person do all their thinking for us
that's inefficient
yeah whoever the person in charge should
always be the person who's the least
stupid at the time
yeah and it should always change power
is fluid yeah
and we have this uh industrialized way
of doing things
i decided naturally i have this idea
that like the person who should be the
president should be
they should find a way to like analyze
people and figure out the person who
least wants to be the president and then
make them do it because
like it's that they won't use their
power for evil
they'll only use their power when they
absolutely have to yeah if you want to
be the president that to me is like the
number one telltale sign that you have a
character defect that makes you ill-fit
to
sit in the seat you know what i mean
like you want to be president like who
are you
like why are you a person who needs that
yeah you shouldn't need to control
people yeah
yeah donald trump's thing was like
pathological his need to have it was
weird
yeah we thought that was normal like
that we should reward that
i didn't reward it i had nothing to do
with it everyone else did okay yeah i'm
not accusing you of anything
but um i'm thinking like um like you
know like
uh being a leader is actually a serving
job so that you're like i want to serve
my community
and uh you know like the ceo is so
exalted nowadays but actually
it should just be one part of a larger
machine instead of giving them 90
percent of all the profits of a company
and their executives if you're a leader
give them like
their fair share which is more than the
others but also like you know they're
just one part like you need
all the other parts and right now we
just love power so much and we're like
oh this guy's powerful let's give him
everything
i think leader is something that should
be determined retroactively you know
what i mean you don't appoint a leader
in advance
and then follow them you just perform
the tasks and then whoever
led is the person you look back and like
they let us
you know but what if you're like
uh going to cross the rio grande and you
had an inflatable boat and you didn't
know how to do it
but there's this one guy who knew how to
do it would you follow him
even though he's telling you what to do
i know how to inflate a boat but what if
he knew
how to what when the best ways were and
where the coast guard wasn't gonna lie
all the ocean shortcuts yeah like you
have to listen to people sometimes yeah
just always not listen to people that's
not that i don't always listen
i mean i'd like if i don't know anything
about anything about something than like
so you're okay being a [ __ ] and doing
what other people tell you if it
makes sense yeah and if it's and if it's
fun or yeah if it's like if it just
resonates with me as like
i guess that's what we're gonna do
because i don't know
but like i am a person who comes off as
argumentative because i'm constantly
like oh but
are we doing this because of this like
it seems like i'm trying to pick apart
like the structure of how things work
and like poke holes in it but i'm really
just like
making sure it's airtight yeah because
you need to know because you're
going to do it your body is on the line
so you don't want to do something where
it doesn't make sense to do and i think
a lot of people
have that part of their brain broken
they're like doing things with their
body or that their mind
doesn't understand and their spirit
doesn't feel
yeah to have this rewarded in our
society to have a 40
hour a week day job like i can't even
imagine
what like i don't think i can do it like
i
like [ __ ] so much respect for anyone
who's [ __ ] capable of it and
it's capable of coming out the other
side like still with any [ __ ]
personality at all it's unreal dude
because i've done it before and it took
like
all my youth was spent in those
situations and like now i know i don't
have the energy for even
one [ __ ] hour working at taco bell
like i don't
have it yeah okay no matter what i did i
could not make myself work at panera
bread for a full day
like i would have to leave sooner or
later well you're like cleaning [ __ ]
and doing all this [ __ ] and uh you put
soup in a
bowl in it made out of bread and you
you're wearing an
apron and you're there it's 6 am and you
have to go to the bathroom and be like
hey can i go to the bathroom and they
yell at you if you have your phone
and you have to like you know deal well
what if
you were in nasa and you were like in
charge of screwing in all the [ __ ]
uh you know like screwing in all the
[ __ ] rivets in the [ __ ] spaceship
if that's your job then you obviously
applied yourself to put yourself in a
situation at nasa otherwise you just
work at like a cabinet store
but that's what i'm saying is like
[ __ ] there should be more
jobs like that like and the fact that we
have meaningless jobs where your whole
life is spent in like
making this nice bread bowl and making
like people
have this consumer experience as a waste
of human uh
potential when we could be going like
having you do something
amazing instead of just like bread bowls
and [ __ ] yeah
and the metal scrapping thing is even
more thankless like as far as
other people's thing like their respect
for you is so
in this way like i should have never
told people
so many things about my personal life
like i
should have never told a soul about my
drug use
like because a large part of how it's
affected my life negatively
is the way that people treat me because
of it you know
which isn't to say that obviously it
affects me and my behavior and my
my mental and physical well i think
that's just society's
stupid people are really shitty about it
yeah i mean that's their fault you know
like we live in a shitty society and if
you act like normal and
tell people what you're going through
then they're going to be like oh you do
drugs
well i heard from reagan and nancy that
you're bad and i'm going to treat you
like the outcast
yeah well i mean people like one of the
things i learned in seattle was if
someone says to you hey
no judgment if you ever need to talk
about anything you can talk to me
don't tell them nothing because they're
trying to get you to tell them something
for some reason like
it's like don't tell that person
anything because people in seattle are
like that
they're very like conniving if
somebody's really your friend you'll
know you can tell them some [ __ ] you
don't need to [ __ ] hear them say that
to you
yeah they don't have physical violence
but they have social violence
yeah yeah the the the [ __ ]
lash outs and like the brutal takedowns
i've seen occur over a goddamn
facebooker absurd
yeah and i guess like i never took it
that seriously because like by the time
the time myspace was a thing i was like
a freshman
and when i remember when my space came
out we all thought it was just a joke
we all thought it was so stupid and we
[ __ ] with it and talked to each other
on it and [ __ ] but
like it was a joke we didn't really take
it seriously if someone was like i was
on myspace and they pissed me off me
like you're
stupid for having that be a thing in
your head and now people
are still in the womb and they have
facebook like they're not even born yet
and they already have facebook they're
ultrasounds yeah
and so that's what they're born into
communicating with each other
in large part through that means like
that to them is
part of the human human contact thing
it's like
we had already gotten way past the point
of all our essential ideas of how we
communicate with each other and like
there are people who've
always had facebook and to them that's
part of
interacting that's a conversation it's
just as intimate as anything else it's
weird
yeah i mean i think digital
communication is a legitimate form of
communication
i think it i think it can be but i think
it robs
people of a lot cause like like 90
percent of our communication is
non-verbal and it has to do with body
language and [ __ ]
and so like it's stupid you like pin it
down to like the most basic form it
could possibly be and it's
and it's abbreviated and it has no tone
and there's like slang in it and it's
inevitably misunderstood almost every
single time
especially when there's a conflict and
then this is mostly how we talk to each
other now
well i think that we should learn how to
talk to each other and express our ideas
through words and not
through the way that we shift our needs
or lift our eyebrows i think that's
some animal stuff and i think i use both
i use both and like i think that they're
both important
yeah i mean they are both important um i
just feel like
if you can't express yourself through
words
and uh like you know sentences then it's
like you probably
aren't saying things that are very
logical well if there are like bare
bones things that like like directions
or
instructions or like like essential
pieces of information like that
that's a text to me yeah but like if you
have something
that you need to say or like like if
you're if you're worried about someone
you call them to me you know what i mean
that's that's that's that's true
grounds for a phone call or if you're
angry with them that's why podcasts are
good
or like videos or like you know that's
like using the digital
with the whatever with the animal
yeah it's just like there's so much lost
in the little things that people do with
their voice that like we don't even
consciously pick up on
we don't even consciously express those
things but they're like
everything it like it's so like all of
these senses
sentences were colored by like little
things that you and i haven't even
really thought about
and like if we were having the same
thing over a text message first of all
we wouldn't have it
we would not have this conversation
period take too much time
yeah and we would be like what the [ __ ]
is this thing talking about like what
are you talking about
you know we were just like one one or
both of us would just walk away from the
keyboard and let the other person tuck
themselves out
it's like you're conveying information
but like if you want to convey emotions
then i think to having the voice that's
important
i think it should just be all tones no
words
and we just like you growl at one
another
just give each other eyes mm-hmm
i wanna remember banjo-kazooie we should
talk like those characters i think he
went hard
i mean i uh i think that uh being able
to talk online is great
and i think it's it's great and i think
talking in person is good also there's
more
possible but i think we should not just
be like
everything has to be in person but no no
the two worlds together whenever
something is even approaching a fight
i'm
like i'll tell someone in a text like
you can either call me or i'll see you
later
like i'm i've like cut them off like i
totally stopped talking to him if it
starts to get into fight territory
but sometimes i like arguing via text
because then you can actually get the
words out and see who has
logical thoughts and who's a [ __ ] but
there's bad grammar there's the thing
about like uh
show me show me three lines from the
most honest of men and i'll have enough
to have him hang by morning like if you
take
the time and just stare at something
that somebody said in
written word you can pick it apart and
eventually it's going to
come apart like eventually you're going
to find the weak spot in it like that's
anything or you could analyze it and
find out what they're actually thinking
and
uh you know just be an awe of
what they're actually conveying right
but most people don't do that they look
for the they look for the
i'm right you're wrong that's because we
have a traumatized society that's just
trying to tear each other down
because they're crabs in a bucket but
that's why i prefer to talk to people
face to face
because they seem to find it a lot
harder to do that if you're just right
there
looking at them you know what i mean
like i've seen people just like mop the
floor with other people's [ __ ] lives
on facebook but they won't do that to
you
you're right there with them i don't
know i don't give a [ __ ] about that you
know if you
can't convey your information through
words then i i don't
know if like we have to always be
talking to each other face to face to
like
communicate ideas oh yeah i love to i
love to play
piece together like the words in a
sentence and i think it's fun to color
things that way but i think that
a lot of a lot of things can't be
explained with words you know yeah
and like when you read something you
have it in your head it's like a tone
you know like you're you're reading it
to yourself
that's what's great about it you can get
into people's heads
and force your ideas to be set in their
heads
i like the idea that like it's a lot
harder to write
um it's a lot harder to write
non-fiction than it is
or a lot harder to write fiction than
just write non-fiction and just because
like in
in in a novel people have to do things
that their character would do and it has
to like kind of make sense
because if they do something like out of
character like that
the reader's gonna be totally taken out
of it but in real life people do [ __ ]
that doesn't make sense all this [ __ ]
time
yeah because that's their character is
trying to find their character yeah
i don't know i i haven't felt like the
main character in this thing for a long
time
well that's not life like we're not main
characters we're one in
a billion yeah seven billion but most
people they put it
in their heads like the narrative is
this is me and i'm doing this and
then like real life clashes with that
and they have to trick themselves into
thinking that the main character
when all evidence points otherwise yeah
and they become crazy yeah i don't know
i [ __ ]
i kind of went into like exile and like
i just like went away
[ __ ] them they don't deserve you i don't
know
[ __ ] animals i don't know i try to
like
think about it a lot as like i wonder if
i'm like totally deluded and like
like what if what if i did something to
deserve this you know like i don't i'm
positive i didn't but like i feel like
it wouldn't have been that severe
were it no or something it's not your
fault it's society's fault i think if
you blame society then you don't have to
torture yourself
i don't really torture myself about it
anymore except for like it's straight up
just like it's not like regret it's not
like
it's inside of the television it's a
rear projector screen it's like a
little ribbon it's like watching
television as me
because the hair is in front of you i
don't know
like you could get a wire and pull it up
oh i could get it out no problem i just
haven't yet um
it's not it's not like i'm angry about
it and it's not like i need to feel like
there's some kind of um
cathartic i i was right everyone else
was wrong moment
like most of the time it's just i i wish
i had my life back you know like that
was that was me
well on my way to being what i wanted
and like i kind of was what i wanted and
i was doing it my way
and i was my own boss and [ __ ] and it
was great and
and i really don't see a person
uh being able to to
spark fire like that again
in their life especially when like it
took me so like
there was months on the street and like
just like pulling myself back together
emotionally and mentally and like now
i'm kind of back together
and i just want to like i just want to
do what i'm doing and and skate by
without
calling too much attention to myself but
i know that that's not the
way to be it's just how i've been you're
scared
yeah because i don't want that i don't
want to do that again though that would
be awful
and like i didn't it was unreal how
thorough it was and how there was like
literally nothing i could do
well you were vulnerable because you
trusted the group the comedy community
and you
worked there you lived within the comedy
community
um and they could take it away and they
did
because they were petty and just because
they could i didn't realize that they
could because so much of it was mine
you know like so not mine but like so
much of it was like
it came from things that i had created
you know
yeah but if you like go back again and
don't rely on them for
the basics and find a way to fund that
on your own
then they can't take anything away from
you again but that seems like it would
be petty because like i could do that
here and it wouldn't have to be about
them
yeah you could and it would be less
difficult or you could go back
to where you were and i don't think that
i did the final chapter to the story
that has a happy ending
i don't think that spot exists anymore
you find a new spot you're better
now so you'd find a bigger and better
way to do it
yeah and this is stunting my growth
being in tucson i think that my comedy
is not
is stunt is stunted it's like
really it's not it's not terrible i i
just like
i was i remember that i was getting
better and better better all the time
before i left seattle like all the time
kicked out by people who aren't getting
better and better but are stagnating
and just like you know socializing and
they kick out the people actually doing
comedy so that they can use the comedy
community to [ __ ]
you know putts around and just like
posturing their big labia lips around
the community and not actually do comedy
and oh dude what's his name you know who
lives here jamie kilstein
did you know that he lives here now oh
he's isn't he the guy that went on rogan
yeah and he was he was like cancelled
hard as [ __ ] he was a male feminist
comedian he like didn't do the clubs he
was just doing these alt rooms and stuff
and he lives here now this tucson's full
of runaways my friend
yeah what is he doing here uh he was
doing mics for a couple of weeks
let's see yeah yeah before the pandemic
yeah he was doing mics for a couple
weeks and like he didn't talk to nobody
he just he just went up and did his time
and then he split good for him
and i had seen i had seen him around
even before that like he
said hey what's up man like as he walked
by me but he's like clearly not here to
talk to anyone so i feel like he's a
chameleon
because he was whatever first and now
he's something else like i forget what
him him and rogan
argued about it didn't seem like they
were arguing to me when i
saw that back and forth well he's
someone that takes the temperature of
the society he's in
and becomes whatever he needs to be yeah
those people
may be sicker than the people there's
nothing wrong with that i mean we need
people who are embodied the voice of
this
generation but the only problem is we
have a sick society
so if you change yourself to be a part
of this society
then you're gonna turn into some weirdo
anti-comedy
feminist yeah i and like i don't know
when i watched him it didn't seem like
there was much
there you know but that was because he
didn't like he
there was no one there for him to pander
to we we're we're in tucson we're
neither club comics nor are we
feminine like there's just a bunch of
people don't know
not a mirror yeah doesn't really know
what to do with himself it was really
weird
every now and again like an established
comic will come through town and they
just like they seem kind of
disoriented like they're in a dream the
whole time you know yeah i mean a lot of
comedy relies on the scene around you
and playing off what was already said
before so when there's nothing there
then they have nothing to bounce off of
because they're not humans they're just
reactions yeah and like
when it gets all insular you just people
kind of blur together
you know like just like oh this is the
there's all four of these guys are kind
of the same guy basically in my head
jamie kilstein no it's just like a
little chunks of comics they're like oh
all of you
do that and like basically i'll take one
i'll take the best one of you because i
know what you all do
yeah when people are like you know
what's that was that comedian is like a
tall weird lanky looking guy and he's
like bald but he like
talks he's like um he's in
what's that louis show that was like
cheers it looks like cheers
louie no it looked like cheers but it
was
it was like super sad you know what i'm
talking about
horus and pete remember that show no
that was a movie right
no was the series oh was it on hbo
no no it was just on his website
actually come to think of it and the
length of the episode
i didn't see it i don't really like
louie's stuff that much kurt metzger
that's the comic i'm thinking
kurt metzger that yeah he's like yeah
like that's a dude where like
so often you go to a club and you're
like you don't you know kurt metzger
already exists you don't need to be here
like you your shift is covered you can
go home
like the like voice the the
like he talks like this a lot he does
this thing a lot well
but like and like he is funny i do like
his stand up but it's like i don't
understand why
like if what you admire about someone is
the the fact that they
sound unique and how they sound like why
would you then emulate
that unique that uniqueness instead of
like
admiring that there's nothing like it
trying to come up with something
different i think it's because we create
nothing people with bland personalities
that's this kind of society we live in
we don't create interesting people
people are going to get
so dull in the next couple years it's
gonna be really weird
because the kids don't even play their
own video games pandemic forces people
to
recognize that there's something bigger
than them and they have to change
yeah life isn't about imposing your will
on the world it's about changing with
the world and adapting to it correctly
and these americans don't have any idea
how to do that they're delusional with
their privilege they just know how to
[ __ ]
uh have wild fantasies not
live in the real world and i think a lot
of people are suffering
and i'm glad they're having mental
breakdowns because their brains are weak
and they deserve to be broken
yeah and like you can come out the other
side with like there will be chunks
missing but if you get broken down and
then you
keep going like you're like the parts
that are left are gonna be like
way sharper and way stronger yeah but
like you gotta lose some [ __ ] along the
way
yeah now you have to deal with something
real and figure out who you really are
there's only like three things that a
person really is and everything else is
changeable
and we hold on to these little parts of
ourselves that are easily changeable
yeah by the way i feel i feel bad for
letting you smoke that
i feel bad the methamphetamine yeah i
feel really bad for like because
that's not like me because liz made you
feel bad no she didn't make me feel bad
she reminded me
how i feel about it like because i don't
like i don't know
what you actually feel yeah because i
don't i like i don't do that like you
you know
you asked me a bunch of times over the
over the last like two days let friends
smoke methamphetamine it's
no i can't i can't let or or stop you
from doing anything yeah
that's like you don't want to be the one
that pushes me over the edge i just feel
that i could have
put more effort into explaining to you
why you might not want to
inside their program no no not like a
dare program like from a first-hand
experience kind of thing where it's like
like not even why you might not want to
just like making sure
you understand what the consequences
isn't that course of power
yeah it's manipulation i think
manipulation has a bad rep
these days but it's like if i want to do
it and we're just two people hanging out
don't bring like artificial like
bureaucracy into it just like
act natural and be like hey i have some
methamphetamine
yeah but what if i was sitting over here
putting like the bottom part of a hot
spatula on my leg over and over again
just because i just [ __ ] with it this is
what i do and if i wanted to do it
no you if i wanted i don't want to do it
and that's a good motivator to not
have me do it because there's no
positive thing to come out of it
but methamphetamine it gave me a good
high
and it made me look at the world
differently and sort of it didn't
get all shimmery dude no it's not really
a visual thing
yes it's not exactly like colors and
[ __ ]
it's like it's just like i was the thing
that you said a second ago
i was just telling someone about this
recently the thing that got me hooked
on g and like a lot of people will say
ghb no
no it's weird people in arizona call
meth g for some reason
yeah and i got me confused a lot because
i always thought they were saying ghb
yeah it's like no they call it g here
but the thing that got me and a lot of
other people
like addicted to g is that it makes you
feel like you are the person you always
knew you were deep down
that's like it's like beyond confidence
it's like this is
his confidence almost feels like uh i'm
gonna put this on so that i can get
through here it's like
you just like oh there you are i knew
you were yeah
it's like a solid emotional foundation
whereas normally it's like i don't know
what to feel should i feel happy am i
because this world is very uh unknown
and scary
uh but with uh when i did
methamphetamine it's like this is how i
feel and it's not a bad emotion it's
stable i can be this
i can have this sort of good emotion i
can stay here
and i don't have to like worry about am
i having the right emotion
because i'm high it's like i have the
motion that i smoked to get and now i
have that now i can live the rest of my
life and figure out
why this car looks so weird and your
head will tell you once you feel that
way that
that good feeling that because it's not
a visual visual thing
and because it's not like having the
same kind of effects like the way it
puts
the head space to put you in your your
brain just
can't not think to itself like i can
sustain this
like i can do this and i can make it a
positive productive thing i know that
i've heard
all these things about other people but
they're they must not be feeling what
i'm feeling
because i'm feeling you're being
affected differently by it
you know or i am or i'm or i'm capable
of managing it where other people
weren't like
anything like well i'm not worried about
that i don't want to
keep doing it i don't know i'm not
worried about you doing it over and over
again
the way that i hadn't i said it to liz i
was like the impression that i got
was that either either you have done it
before and you were bullshitting me
or your or you haven't done it before
and you're probably not going to seek it
out again
so it's one of those two things either
either you've done it before and you
kind of do it here and there and you
just like fed me some [ __ ]
or or you've tried it now and you're
really not compelled to have
more that much you like you might do it
here and there but that's it i mean it
was a good high
yeah but you know like marijuana does
something similar it's not like that
different
but i mean marijuana i got used to it
and
sort of you know it's different but um
things that speed you up i think is a
real danger because then it just keeps
ramping you up and up but weed sort of
sort of slows you down it's like a
natural
it just sort of forces you to not kill
yourself you know overdo it
uh so it's a good thing to be addicted
to
yeah but it's not like you felt bad
about that yeah i believe you felt bad
that you gave me
methamphetamine well because like i
don't know it's not
it's not good for anyone really like
even like even though it was like even
if you have in your head like i want to
have all the different experiences
it's just like drugs but yeah it is we
prescribe that
and they shouldn't well i say this
yeah the morbidly obese
um people with brains that want it or
need it or are improved by it
like who like you i don't know that it's
improving you
well then why are you doing it because i
want to
yeah that's that's a good sign that you
should do it
i don't know i don't know about that
yeah i mean if you want to do it
then it's like your brain is seeking it
out because it's making you feel a
certain way
but what about like people's love to do
it puppies and [ __ ] like
it's because they want to do it oh it
makes them feel good
don't don't even think about it just hop
right in
um yeah you shouldn't [ __ ] puppies but i
think that uh
if you can sort of recognize that it's a
prescript it's a drug and that drugs are
a certain thing and
there's a certain way to handle it
correctly yeah i agree
it's smart to do it but [ __ ] puppies
is not
not uh not great i mean it's not it's
not great but it's all right
it'll get you where you're going but um
yeah i mean i think that
uh i should have done it i don't
think that i should have not i should
have not done it it wasn't weird
watching you film it at all because i
was like okay this is like he's
he's like doing this from a journalistic
standpoint if this is what's happening
like he's just
doing it so that he can say he did it to
someone someday
yeah it's like it puts it into context
i'm not just doing it
it's because i hate this day and i just
want to escape i'm like i want to see
what it's like and
a lot of people do meth and there's a
reason and i don't think all those
people are stupid idiots who are just
addicted i think that's a
stupid narrative yeah that we tell each
other
i used to archive [ __ ] like that so much
more diligently
but now that like i i'm concerned with
what is done with content
once you've let go of it like i barely
put anything anywhere for anyone to see
you know that's sad that we have this
technology and you're not using it
it's like the superpower and you're just
like whatever
i use it it's just like i use it very
sparingly
to occasionally remind people that i
even exist
and like well you know if you use it it
makes you feel bad
then it's not a good thing to use yeah
it doesn't just make me feel bad it's
like
i don't know i got weird [ __ ]
body image issues and [ __ ] you don't
want to portray yourself in a certain
way or
show people no i'm not an image of
yourself that's not you
i'm comfortable with being however i am
but i don't like that people pretend to
not understand that like
you feel differently sometimes than
other times delete their comment
and you create a world among um
that's in your in your head and you
create that world online
yeah that was i mean that's not a
terrible idea but like i don't know that
like
i just i don't know if i have it in me
to [ __ ] push back a pill against
resistance like that again the uh
seattle incident yeah i mean but that's
not digital that was like one
person no it was like it was a lot of
[ __ ] all
like yeah they set off the [ __ ] spark
and then it was carried out
through facebook like all over facebook
it's like if they're gonna do that then
do it and then in the real world
just keep going to mike's yeah and
they'll see you and have to eventually
come face to face with reality
and they'll feel stupid because they um
they're violent narcissistic little
american shits
who can't think about anyone but
themselves and they're just using
conservative tactics that they learn
from their parents to push forward
whatever narcissistic vision they have
you know and like they're they're told
that like oh you must have been raised
real well to have all this self-esteem
you know i mean it's like to value
self-worth above everything else it
means that you had a well-rounded
childhood
yeah because you value yourself
but actually you had a terrible
childhood i know had a pretty good
childhood
it was just boring i can see that
yeah this world that we're trying to
strive for is not worth striving for
uh we need a new vision we need to
change our culture and society but we're
too afraid of change
we want everything to stay the same
because that's safe even though people
are dying
i don't yeah i'm comfortable with some
massive area
yeah i mean we need it i think it sounds
[ __ ] great dude we can't keep doing
this forever
i'm all the time like so if i ever stare
up at the moon for for a long time i get
like my heart starts to beat faster
because i just think like
one of these days something's gonna just
and just like knock that thing into
rubble and it might happen right now
while i'm sitting here
you know like an asteroid or whatever
you know like eventually whatever it's
gonna be is gonna happen and you might
be able to watch it it might happen in
an instant but like
whatever it is is gonna be here sooner
or later
yeah like we're not that special we're
gonna go
eventually we're very tiny so we might
as well
do whatever we want yeah
um yeah
i mean i just feel like
we chatty yeah he's a terrible person
yeah and she i remember when she started
comedy
and i remember before she started comedy
and it was a better time before
she started comedy yeah it was really
really bad
but i haven't really hung out with her a
lot i'm just
she's surmising and also like i left
for new york and i used seattle
[ __ ] use it for whatever i needed i
[ __ ] left
i was like there was the mindset that i
had in seattle was like i was like
elevating from the ground that like i
was like
tide rising all the boats go up kind of
thing i was like
constantly putting money in other
people's pockets and like you're
constantly doing like a stand-up comedy
as individual
i know you gave too much of yourself to
this community and they
[ __ ] you i just thought it was not not
just a good idea for them but for me you
know i was like i thought that this is
what you do
this is how you get notoriety is what
you failed
to realize is that this society is evil
and you should not give them
anything you should you should thrive in
spite of them
i i feel that there have been varying
degrees of relocation
i'm just kidding there's some good parts
of people
but i just feel like america's so
violent and
aggressive and they just use people like
resources
and in korea it's like you're korean you
know like they
rape and kill each other too but far
less actually i don't know the murder
rate
it's probably it's like they
they respect each other they have this
like thing where they're like you're not
just like a slave that i'm gonna use
you're korean you know we're all korean
and we all like care for each other but
here in america it's like
people are resources and people treat
each other like [ __ ] like this guy at
the bar today he was just like
talking non-stop remember that guy that
you were yelling at with a hawaiian
shirt or whatever at the bar
oh yeah like his they always are he's
like
it's like benign but it's still
uh evil it's like he just thinks that he
gets to take up this much space
and i mean he does get to
yeah i mean he's going to the limit of
what humans are allowed to do but that's
not it
he doesn't need it he doesn't need to
take up that much attention he's just
taking it because he can and not because
yeah but i mean what's so special about
anyone like yeah i know but it's not
like you can just
ruin everyone else's night because no
one's special
yeah i think there are better more
complex reasons to ruin other people's
lives
like yeah pleasure of the game
it's your joy you're an artist
yeah you destroy women and then
no i mostly just destroy myself and then
everyone gets mad at me for it because
they probably think that i can
be taking care of myself better and i
don't you're like teetering on the edge
of just being
the scariest person ever and people are
like that
sound that looks that looks like it's
going to fall off any moment
yeah and then they [ __ ] push you
no some people come running like it's
been my experience that like when
whenever people are in a weird like
transitional
period in their lives they find their
way over to me like when they're like i
don't know where there was like all this
other stuff that was happening but i'm
not going back to that
i don't really know what's happening
next and then they they feel like they
can talk to me
because it feels like i think it's like
it feels like i've been there and you
can tell that i've been there for a long
time
and it's and that you can still laugh
while you're there and then it's like
at a bus stop yeah bus stop i mean i
feel like
you attract those people like some
comedian had a joke i think it was jason
goat who was like i
have the kind of face where people tell
me about whole episodes of sense of
anarchy
and you have that like i have the
opposite like
i i attract people too who are like
boring and want
someone benign who's not gonna you know
rock the boat
too much but you are attracting all
these crazy people and you're playing
the video game
like you're playing a different game for
me so it's like easy for me to not do
meth but for you it's like all the meth
heads come to you
yeah it's like but also you attracted
yourself it's like a symbiotic
relationship
anybody who's ever been in recovery will
tell you like you don't need money
you know like it doesn't matter like if
if you want it you'll get it
it doesn't matter what you have to do to
get it you'll get it so
it's not about money it's like at this
point it's just about [ __ ] not
sleeping for
24 hours straight i don't want to
[ __ ] sleep all that time
i slept a lot today cool this felt good
i'm not gonna sleep tonight because i
took the puff of marijuana this
afternoon
and uh that kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] me up
like um
molly molly keeps me up i hate molly
yeah suicide tuesdays or whatever what's
the worst
what can it come down there but i don't
think it's meth that's destroying people
i think it's capitalism and the lack of
resources and
lack of a functional society
because if we had a functional society
people wouldn't have to go to meth to
feel good they would feel good because
they get to rivet into
the screws in a space shuttle that's a
high
yeah but you can't really do much with
it that's why i like comedy dude because
this
the society is so [ __ ] stupid that
the best thing i can do is make fun of
it and just like
have fun yeah i mean because
it's like nine times out of ten how i'm
trying to think of things anyways
because it's like i've been through so
much that now
terrible things i am able to just like
okay well
this will be what i have to deal with
now and
you know you have ptsd it's not even
ptsd it's like
i ptsd my way through and now i don't
care
like if something if something little
tiny thing
happens it pisses me off a lot but like
it like liz knocked over my old
television and it was a big
nice smart tv it was an lg it was bigger
than this one it was [ __ ] amazing
and she was just drunk and knocked it
over and like i didn't even think about
it i was like well it's okay
we got a new one found that one side
yeah so that's not a big deal because
it's not
you know getting homeless
and ostracized from a community that you
love
so it feels like nothing
i'm not a part of any community
you are whether you like it or not
that's what the pandemic should have
taught us
was that a spit bubble gum
chew gum but i think uh blue moon was a
good mic
i think uh remember the comedy crawl
space no
in the unicorn the show that andrew
murphy and i ran
when we had the dating game oh yeah with
the
that really popular bar yeah the unicorn
that was [ __ ] crazy dude dude that
show was great right
and you guys had like people come up and
like you know wear a little unicorn
yeah people were trying to just party
there and they were loud and [ __ ] and we
were all
there all night dude like remember uh
daniel gray
yeah we had him do the dating game and
[ __ ] and like when the curtain went down
and the girl looked over and saw
him he was like hey i didn't know you
weren't gonna be in a wheelchair
good line he was funny yeah he was great
yeah uh have the wheel yeah man oh dude
did we ban someone every show i forget
who the first person was that's a great
play on cancel culture
yeah it didn't even occur to me
that was the bunch of shows naked brunch
patriot hacks which was the festival
held in the backyard
i don't remember that one yeah brody
remember brody kelly
yeah he's from portland he moved up
right i have no idea he blocked me some
time ago
why what'd you do um i don't know
he's he went off his meds again and and
i didn't hear from him forever
and now i don't know where he is i don't
were you guys friends
yeah he was like he was like my best
friend but dude then you guys he stopped
taking lithium man and like he was
really [ __ ] up he was he was
completely [ __ ]
inconsolably insane he was insane
yeah yeah that sucks and like eventually
he just blocked me and i'm not sure why
but i don't know that i care to find out
either
maybe you weren't the best for him at
the time oh yeah i mean
that would be he didn't want to do math
okay well i hadn't been doing it at that
point be
chatty i had never met he knew where you
were headed i had never met me chatting
until like
years later she was the one who got me
into this [ __ ] i'm telling you
damn and you still do it don't you want
to like
not be living in the shadow of this
dramatic event
yeah i very much like that but i don't
know that that has as much to do with
this
as why don't we go back to seattle
establish a community ostracize the
ostracizers
and shame them publicly i think that
timing is everything on that yeah
first you get on conan so
get writing did you know i was on the
front page of funnier dave
yes you told me okay
um yeah that's cool i don't have
very many credits that's the only good
one i have
what are you on there for we're doing 10
minutes of stand up
10 minutes is a long time what was the
general vibe of the set that got you
famous
it was it was just like my submission
video was so
really i'm like clean cut looking and it
was uh oh it was like one of the first
for the record shows at jai tai
you're in there
[Music]
yeah so it was like a dry thai crowd
capitol hill young hipsters
and you just like spoke to them about
the drug experience no i didn't
hardly talk about drugs at all
such an ugly backdrop
yeah remember when i used to do that bit
where i had the kazoo up my sleeve and i
was throwing at the bell
yes
yeah no
okay well you gotta scrap and clean and
sleep
i'm so tired how do you wanna end this
podcast um
i don't know what are you what what what
do you plan to do
next where am i going to see you again
do you think i'm going to go to austin
i'm going to camp out
see if this fourth wave hits or not um
fourth wave
coronavirus oh right right you're just
like staying away from everyone
yeah i love it i uh i find
society to be toxic
and gross and i i love that the mental
state that i get in when i'm alone
don't you think that like i love being
alone solitude is great
yeah i mean i would rather be around
healthy people but that's not an option
yeah there's a difference between
solitude and
isolation like solitude is healthy and
and pleasant but isolation is like i
wake up
and i like go hiking i go into the
mountains climb a mountain
and it's like that's like my day oh and
it's just
it's so much better and we are in this
society
and we sacrifice so much to be in it
we sacrifice so much of our mental
health and people don't even realize it
because they never do what i'm doing
they never just go out because they
don't have vans that they live in
clear creek you should go check it out
is there a lot of people there
no you have to go deep in it to get away
from like at the front there's
typically a lot of people in it yeah but
like if you just like go
the way that i imagine you would anyways
which wouldn't occur to anyone there's a
way that you could go like you just like
be walking i'll go
yeah go how far away is it from here
it's been so long since i've been there
um it's in between here in new mexico
okay well let's end this podcast what do
you want to say to people
like what it like i'm going to put it up
um let me know if you want me to edit
anything out but like
i'm going to put it up you know
generally who is going to listen to it
like probably like seven people
i don't i don't i actually don't i don't
know who you still [ __ ] with i don't
know who still [ __ ] with you
well just imagine my audience
anything you want to say to these people
that are on my facebook
no the people that i think would listen
to it that i imagined would
uh we would both know would probably
have anywhere from an in
a indifferent to high opinion of me
that's good yeah i don't i i'm sure that
they're like oh he's fine or
some of them might be like i don't think
he's very funny but i don't have a
problem with him that would probably be
the worst thing anyone would say
and they would be they would be full of
[ __ ] but like i i don't know i guess
uh i guess it's just weird to think that
somebody would be listening and thinking
about
the situation in seattle again but i
need to get over it again i just need to
keep [ __ ] picking away at that [ __ ]
yeah go to new york or l.a go to la la's
close to here
or go to austin yeah you live in a
mobile home
yeah i know i'd like i'd like to go to
austin i think
but then there's also like the part of
me that's like i love fugazi and i love
like punk rock music and like there's
really not much
here yet but there's like these huge
gaps that like
someone just needs to fill them you know
and i've thought about filling them
because i know how to do it i've done it
before
i just don't know if i want to do that
again or if it would be better for me to
like
me but i gotta not i gotta stop doing
neither i gotta like
do something yeah i would say
throw away about eighty percent of what
you have in here and then just
do comedy every day or punk rock music
whatever you're talking about
punk rock comedy no it's it's the diy
ethics behind the punk rock music and
like the application of it onto comedy
yeah you're good at flyering and it's
like there's not there's not a bunch of
different ways to do
comedy successfully you know what i mean
you either got to be this or you got to
be that you can be like an alternative
comic or you can be a club comic
um and there's no way to really be
something
totally completely off the ball
different you know
but that's just because nobody's done it
yet yeah i mean
someone just has to do it sebastian
maniscalco is pretty different
i think his comedy's kind of run the
middle he's funny but it's not
the way that he did it the way he went
about delivering it was interesting
okay yeah i mean sure um
i would like to say to the people
listening
that we are just two
young gun comics grinding it out
figuring it out you know just like
putting in the work
and um we have a perspective that needs
to be heard
and everyone's perspective needs to be
heard
and uh to think that someone's
perspective
is too controversial or too
edgy or too dull or boring is
obviously wrong
and if that's what you think then you
just don't understand humanity because
you're
so used to seeing humans as like little
play things
commodities
anyways
should we end it yeah all right
you